on va parler des cahiers de doléances
maintenant fin 2018 en pleine crise les
jets les jaunets maires ruraux propose
d'ouvrir des cahiers de doléances pour
canaliser la colère emmanuel mâcon
promet qu'ils seront analysés restituer
en ligne à l'ensemble des citoyens alors
la promesse at elle était tenue et que
sont devenus ces cahiers de doléances on
regarde ce reportage de samia de chirée
clara barge il a gardé une copie de
chaque témoignage
fin 2018 en pleine crise des gilet jaune
fabrice dalongeville ouvre dans sa
mairie un cahier de doléances
francis frizon habitants de ce village
du val d'oise depuis 40 ans n'a pas
hésité à y écrire ses propositions avec
ça c'est moi alors je vais en trois
parties les institutions les inégalités
et l'union européenne sur les inégalités
j'avais dit économique et social les
problème d'échelle de salaire plafonner
la rémunération de responsables
d'entreprises anne émond raisonnable l
époque à 10000 mairie avaient ouvert
leur porte pour recueillir par écrit les
revendications des citoyens et tenter de
canaliser une colère qui s'exprime
jusque là dans la rue tout notre réseau
totalement exceptionnel de pouvoir
exprimer directement
avec l'idée que
les ses expressions vont être prises en
compte en tout cas au moins lui parler
les responsables politiques du pays donc
lutter hors de question de ne pas fait
cette occasion sur les 500 habitants
dauger 120-112 sont venus noircir les
pages du cahier de doléances certains
ont longuement préparé des contributions
de plusieurs pages je pense que d'une
certaine manière les gens ont réfléchi
et là et qu'on soit pour ou contre le
mouvement des gilet jaune finalement ce
qui reste derrière c'est un pays qui
fait de la politique qui qui voit bien
qu'ils identifient bien là où il ya des
difficultés qui a des idées
et c'est oui à partir du moment où vous
avez des revendications des habitants
des citoyens cela participe à la
gouvernance locale
ça paraît assez évident ne pas les
respecter c'est ça sert à rien de mettre
en place la possibilité de de décrire de
coucher sur le papier des doléances et
c'est pour pas tenir compte quoi c c'est
de la pure démagogie voire du populisme
en fait pure démagogie ou exercice
inédit de démocratie participative
deux ans plus tard les fameux cahiers de
doléances rempli par les français sont
désormais conservés dans les archives
départementales comme ici en
seine-et-marne de me prendre un registre
pour la commune parents de bois sizzla
bertrand mes souhaits pour l'europe
unifiée les taxes et impôts dans tous
les pays pour éviter les paradis fiscaux
taxer les gars femmes 250k y est venue
des 500 communes du département sont
conservés dans une quinzaine de boîtes
théoriquement accessible à tous mais que
personne n'est jamais venu consulter je
ne suis pas certain non plus que le
grand public
ait connaissance que ces documents se
trouve aux archives départementales bien
entendu une série communication a été
assurée en 2019 sur le sujet ces
documents sont des trésors inestimables
pour comprendre la motivation des
citoyens leurs colères leurs
propositions le sens qu'il souhaite
donner à la vie publique et je suis
certain que le temps viendra où des
historiens des chercheurs se pencheront
sur ces documents à l'origine les 16300
cahier de doléances devait aussi être
accessible en ligne pour tout le monde
ils ont bien été numérisés et stocké ici
à la bibliothèque nationale de france
mais seuls les chercheurs peuvent les
consulter car les témoignages n'ont pas
été anonymisés hors la loi protège la
vie privée de leurs auteurs il était
question de rendre publiques et
accessible l'ensemble des cahiers
citoyens du grand débat national est
bien plus de trois ans après la promesse
n'est pas tenue et fait cai et on ne
sont pas disponibles en ligne la
conséquence à ce à court terme c'est que
ça peut nourrir en fait ce qui était
censé combattre le grand débat national
c'est-à-dire la défiance envers le
personnel politique c'est à dire que
vous ne pouvez pas dire aux gens et bien
qu'ils viennent participer à ce type
d'opération de démocratie participative
et ne pas aller au bout de vos
engagements au risque voilà de créer
plus de défiance que c'était sensé en
résoudre le collectif rendez les
doléances milite désormais depuis deux
ans pour que le gouvernement lance enfin
le travail d'anonymisation des cahiers
de doléances et les rendent accessible
en ligne pour tous les citoyens emmanuel
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut dire que
fait khayat doléances ont été utiles
ils ont été ils ont tout là soulevé des
espoirs ils ont ils ont réveillé le
l'envi politique comme je n'ai
d'ailleurs le moment des faits les
jeunes allaient commencer à le faire
parce que c'était une forme quand même
d'université politique et celle ouvert
en ce mouvement des gens qui n'avaient
au fond pas réfléchi aux institutions
qu'elle vivait au point qu'ils vivaient
ont commencé à sa part les référendum
rick
participation citoyenne et d'ailleurs il
ya pas mal gilet jaune qui aujourd'hui
sont sur les listes législatives donc ce
ses cahiers de doléances c'était une
occasion assez unique pour des gens de
s'exprimer enfin c'est ce qu'on voit
dans ce reportage
beaucoup de gens et à peu près je crois
2 millions de contributions c'est énorme
on écrit y ont cru alors beaucoup chez
les gilet jaune disait que c'était juste
une manoeuvre politique pour enterrer le
mouvement il ya d'ailleurs eu un vrai
débat organisé par les gilets jaunes
pour contrecarrer ce grand débat mais au
final on trouvait des finalement des
doléances très similaires dans tous et
c'est à dire
beaucoup alors évidemment sur l'économie
avec ce qu'on a vu la dent un portage
c'est-à-dire plus d'égalité une
le problème de la finance internationale
le problème de dégâts fin de la saison 6
entre guillemets sur le travail de voilà
et puis et puis beaucoup de demande
justement de démocratie participative de
transparence les publics
c'est juste qu'ils revenaient de manière
extrêmement forte
et là on est quand même dans une
situation absolument enfin c'est
terrible c'est terrible c'est à dire que
quand le maire dit que ça va réveiller
la défiance est évidemment savent que on
se retrouve face à un exercice les gens
ont participé
ils y ont cru et ils ont joué le jeu ils
ont fait des efforts on licencie des
pages et des mairies certains gros
effort il a fallu trouver les lieux et
il a fallu pas vraiment pour les mères
c'était un gros effort pour les gens des
gens ont créé des pages et des pages se
sont livrés ils ont réfléchi ils ont
discuté c'était un âne et un énorme
travail collectif et au final en abouti
à rien on n'aboutit à rien donc oui oui
en fait ceux qui pensaient que c'était
juste de la manipulation aujourd'hui on
peut dire peut-être qu'ils ont eu raison
de faire de l'effet inverse c'est-à-dire
là où emmanuel magat voulait faire
parler les gens il l'a montré par la
preuve qu'en fait ça ne servait à rien
c'est ça le problème c'est un problème
mais mais vraiment qu'ils que je
trouvais moi mais terrible c'est à dire
que là pour pour la présidentielle il
refait beaucoup de marche y ait beaucoup
de terrain et ses cahiers doléances y
reviennent dans dans les propos des gens
les gens disent on a participé on a
bossé mais son ou une fois de plus on
s'est fait avoir sa vision crue on leur
a demandé d'y croire ils se sont un peu
réveillé et paf
de nouveau il se dit bon ben voilà les
politiques se fiche de nous moi je
trouve ça terrible en fait terrible oui
alors le premier point un petit rappel
et cahill ou les ans cette hausse a été
créé pendant la révolution française et
c'est vrai que en gros ça peut se
résumer à la nuit du 4 août l'abolition
des privilèges donc ça aboutit très
concrètement et très vite lens heurte à
deux difficultés
la première c'est qu'en effet on est
dans une sa confirme et qu'on soit
société fragmentaire chiper disait que
chaque heure est venue avec
ses idées ses frustrations ses colères
ses propositions et qui était beaucoup
similaires
oui alors il y avait eu un fils
directeurs qui en effet ce taux pause
inégalités et stoppe en gros pouvoir de
la finance sur l'industrie sur le
service public etc je pense qu'il aurait
fallu retenir jusqu'à une ou deux lignes
et ne pas partir dans tous les sens
pour éviter cette dispersion aujourd'hui
en effet comme l'a très bien à quoi
s'attendre archives ce sont des
documents qui vont servir aux chercheurs
et aux historiens mais qui ne font pas
avancer la politique après comme un
petit point c'est bien de manifester sur
les ronds points c'est bien d'aller
remplir et cadore ans mais la démocratie
ça reste quand même le bulletin dans
l'urne or ceux qui ont signé ce que
manifester je suis pas sûr qu'ils soient
tous à aller voter donc à un moment il
faut être cohérent c'est à dire quand on
avait encore l'abstention on peut pas
dire qu'il y ait une envie de participer
à la vie publique désolé mais il
n'existe pas de meilleur système que le
butin d'accord on est dans une forme de
paradoxe entre des français qui
demandent à avoir plus de sympathie et
en même temps une abstention en descente
et c'est pas un paradoxe c'est bien
c'est bien le signe de la défiance
vis-à-vis dvd ellisdon qui considèrent
qu'ils ne les représentent plus ne peut
pas reprocher à des gens ne pas aller
voter on peut s'interroger excusez moi
sur pourquoi ne vont-ils pas voter et
pourquoi n'arrive-t-on plus aujourd'hui
à les convaincre que l'élu peut porter
la parole des citoyens et travailler et
travailler pour lui cette défiance elle
est là on la voit élection après
élection tous les cinq ans et à chaque
élection on se dit oh là là cette
abstention on voit la colère on voit le
vote pour les partir le pôle de 30
espèces que nous que ça existait un
problème de représentation qui est qui
qui est réel et tant qu'on s'attaquera
pas ce problème de robe blanche désolé
il verrait douze candidats à la
présidentielle je veux dire qui
représentait tout le spectre politique
il est aux législatives beaucoup de
candidats qui représente encore plus que
spectra présidentielle donc il y à leur
présentation la difficulté c'est après
quelle marge de manoeuvre on les élus
pour peser sur la société ce que n'ont
pas admis les gilles et jean lescure
ample et cahiers c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
finance et quand même aussi un peu la
technocratie ont pris le dessus sur ceux
qui sont censés représenter les citoyens
c'est plus ça que
que la défiance envers les mêmes choses
qui peut les manuels pour conclure
est-ce que du coup comme ces cahiers de
doléances n'ont pas été pris en compte
est ce que ça veut dire qu'un mouvement
de colère peut repartir face à un
mouvement de colère on peut jamais le
prévoir donc on a après oui beaucoup
pensent que ça risque de
barder moment alain je connaissais bien
envie de repartir il ya une grosse
lassitude aussi donc
voilà je n'ai pensé c'est compliqué de
prévoir mais en tout cas ce que l'on
sent son terrain c'est que cette colère
ce ce manque de deux fois dans dans le
système politique dans les gens qui nous
gouvernent il est là en permanence en
permanence et 7,7 collet ya un moment
elle se traduit souvent par le terrain
[Musique]